first of all I'd like to welcome you all
here today
and I'm happy to announce as you know
that Grayson will be open to the public
as a Memorial Museum to Elvis Presley
as Colonel Parker invited to this
gee did we did we send him a telegram
that's right that's right he's not in
the media
at least not enough no
public it's been my home for a long time
and uh it had to go beyond that and I
guess reality and economics is a major
point
so it has to go beyond emotions is the
upkeep on Graceland terribly draining on
the estate very much so absolutely this
has been a major point
and
I've been of course the major decision
of why we are opening it
did you talking just about Sunday
Graceland opening to the public yes
absolutely Elvis was very proud of his
home and anytime guest would come in he
was more than willing to show show them
throughout the house and I think he'd be
very pleased to know that it was shown
in this way I'm very happy I always feel
you're going to get some criticism no
matter what you do I found in life that
you know you're not always gonna be uh
or people are not always going to think
you're doing the right thing and if
there's to be a Graceland at all this is
the way we have to do it uh thank God
that we're doing it privately you know
we didn't really work out with the state
and with the city but we have control
and and we're doing it I believe in the
way that Elvis would love and appreciate
and we're maintaining it and preserving
it for him so you know what can I say I
think Lisa at the time that she's of age
will be very happy that it's done this
way
you think she ever wants to live here
I don't know but if she does it's hers
and it'll all be preserved for her I
don't think it could be if it was done
any other way did you'll notice there is
no
um kind of construction going up on the
grounds that's permanent if ever she
decided at the age of 25 that she wanted
to maintain as her personal home is
was for her to do just that yes
she's very pleased about it she is very
proud of it and she feels the same that
she would love people to see Graceland
she's a 14 years old and enjoying her
life which is very good she's into
roller skating I think she's a real
typical teenager
[Music]
foreign
yes I have mixed emotions about it it is
quite uh it's something of which um
it was a long time to make the decision
but it's something that I feel is it's
very good and very positive and
especially the way that we're doing it
uh
I think it's very good
there's been a lot of discussion as to
whether five dollars was really adequate
to cover all of your expenses well
we're projecting a lot of people and
especially I think also with the world's
fair opening and we want to make it so
that people all over the world can come
I know that we have people throughout
Europe all over actually all over and we
want to make it possible for them and
everyone to see it and five dollars may
seem you know not a lot but I think
we're going to give it a try we want to
do the best for the people
here
okay thank you very much
[Music]